[موسيقى]
اقصاد محش جدا مخوخ داخليا
بني ادم بيشقى ويتعب ويعرق وهو الاخر
وينتج وبعدين يجي يمد ايديه عشان نشوف
الدخل ايه القطاعات الاساسيه في اي اقتصاد
هي الزراعه والصناعه واحنا في الواقع
اهملنا الاثنين
حاول في الرؤيه عفوا للتعبير انما انا
بقوله وانا مطمئن جدا الارض دي اصلا اللي
بتبيع وتشتريه ارض الشعب مش ارض الحكومه
الخبراء الصندوق حينما يفيدون الى مصر
بالمناسبه ينزلون في فنادق خمس نجوم لا
يرون من القاهره الى النيل العظيم
والمكاتب الحكوميه الفخمه وهم في عزله
تماما عما يحدث على ارض الوا
قع اذا كنت هتوجه للصندوق النقد انا اعتقد
انه ينبغي ان يستبعد تماما موضوع تخفيض
الجنائي انما انا عندي شك كبير
علماء اذا كان مثلا عوائد مشروع العاصمه
الاداريه الجديده ولا العلمين الجديده على
سبيل المثال عواده اكثر من التكاليف
مساء الخير على حضراتكم مساء الخير معالي
الدكتور مساء الخير لك وللساده المشاه
دين ربنا يخلي
حضرتك تور
يعني احنا الحقيقه انا كان في مخطط
النهارده مجموعه من الافكار هنتطرحها في
اطار
العنوان الرئيسي لسلسله الحلقات ديت وهي
افكار حضرتك ولكن
جت كميه كبيره جدا من التعليقات والاسئله
خصوصا عن الحلقه الماضيه اللي هي الحلقه
التانيه كان المقصود من الحلقه التانيه ان
انا اعرف راي حضرتك في صندوق النقد لكن
كلام حضرتك تطرق بعد الحديث عن صندوق
النقد لاداء الحكومه والمجموعه الاقتصاديه
وتصورك للخروج من الازمه الاقتصاديه
اعطيتنا عناوين وتركت مساحه كبيره للفضول
لمعرفه التفاصيل
سؤالي باختصار لانه علشان نشبع فضول الناس
قبل ما اسال حضرتك عن مزيد من التفاصيل
للخروج من الازمه الاقتصاديه ممكن تقول
لنا ملامح الاداء الاقتصادي للحكومات
المتعاقبه في الثمان سنوات الماضيه هو
طبعا يعني
[موسيقى]
اساسيات التي طبقت في السنوات الثماني
الماضيه
نتج عنها باختصار ونفصله
اقتصاد
محش جدا
ضعيف امام الصدمات الخارجيه
مخوخ داخليا
زاد ارتباطه بالخارج وضعوا في ارتباطه
داخليا
وايضا
كان له افرازات
مجتمعيه خطيره اهمها تراجع العداله
الاجتماعيه تراجع واحنا بنقيم اي حاله
اقتصاديه
حط مبدئيا للتقييم مبدا الاول هو الكفاءه
المبدا التاني هو العداله
بمعنى الكفاءه تعني انك انت تحصل من قدر
معين من الموارد على اكبر مردود ممكن
والعداله تعني انه يكون هناك قدر من
التكافؤ في الفرص بين المواطنين والفئات
الاجتماعيه داخل مكتمل او
دي بنسميها العبايه الاجتماعيه والاخرى
نسميها الكفاءه الاقتصاديه فاذا اضطرب
الميزان بمعنى انه مال اكتر للعداله على
حساب الكفاءه تحدث مشكله ولو بعد حين واذا
مال الميزان في اتجاه العداله على حساب
الكفاءه ايضا تحصل مشكله ولو بعد حين فمن
هذا المنظور بنقول
انه ما حدث خلال السنوات الثمانيه الماضيه
في الواقع ان الميزان لم يمل
نحو الكفاءه على حساب العداله ولم يمل نحو
العداله بعيدا عن الكفاءه انما مال بعيدا
عن الاثنين بمعنى لم يكن لدينا كفاءه
اقتصاديه ولم تتحقق لدينا عداله
الاجتماعيه يمكن الناس تتسائل وزاره
التضامن بتعمل ايه وانت كنت مسؤول عن
وظائف
هنا فكرون بتمييز مهم جدا احنا بنقوله
تمييز بين العداله الاجتماعيه والحمايه
الاجتماعيه
فرق جوهري مهم
وفي المؤتمر الاخير كحكايه وطن حصل خلط
بين الاثنين كان
معظم الكلام عن الحمايه الاجتماعيه ولكن
بصيغه العداله الاجتماعيه الفرق
الحمايه الاجتماعيه انك انت لما يكون عندك
فئات
ضعيفه اقتصاديه
وعاجزه عن العمل بما يولد دخل كريم
ومناسب وكافي لها
فيتدخل المجتمع
باليات متعدده احيانا حياه كريمه احيانا
معاش الضمان الاجتماعي الى اخره اليد
لاعانه هذه الفئات
اما العداله الاجتماعيه فتعني في الواقع
اداره الاقتصاد بما يوفر قدر متكافئا من
الفرص
على تلات اتجاهات
الفرص بين الفئات الاجتماعيه التي تعيش في
نفس الفتره فلو قلنا مثلا عندنا فقره
وتقسيط الحال واغنيه
العداله تعني هنا انا بوزع الفرص بقدر من
التكافؤ بين هذه الفئات الثلاث ديسميها
العداله الافقيه
او انه بوزع الفرص بين الجيل الحالي
والاجيال القادمه هذه العداله الراسيه انك
انت مثلا لو قارنت بين جيل الاباء وجيل
الابناء
هل فرص موزعه بعداله ده سؤال مهم جدا
الاتجاه الثالث هو العداله بين الاماكن
عندك هنا ريفو حضر عندك بحري والصعيد عندك
ساعل ساحل وداخل
ولابد الا يميل الميزان
لطرف على حساب طرفها مثلا في حالتنا احنا
اهمالنا الصعيد لفتره طويله جدا جدا
ونتج عن هذا ان احنا حاليا بنحاول يعني
تعويض ما فات من خلال برنامج لتنميه الايه
التنميه الصعيد فعايز اقول انه تقديري انا
الشخصي على مدى السنوات الثماني الماضيه
اختل ميزان العداله الاجتماعيه واضطرب
والضربه مبدا
الكفاءه الاقتصاديه طيب على ارض الواقع
نعمل ايه دلوقتي انت عندك انا قلت اقتصاد
هش
بمعنى انه لما روسيا تحارب اوكرانيا ترتفع
اسعار الحبوب مثلا او اسعار الطاقه او
اسعار الاسمده
بينتج عن هذا عجز عن تامين الاحتياجات
الاساسيه لهذا المجتمع وارتفاع كبير في
الاسعار كما نشاهد حاليا ما هو سبب بسبب
انه
اهملنا قضيه الانتاج
وعايز اقول ليس فقط اقتصاديه انما حتى
ثقافيا في الخطاب العام لم نعد مشغولين
بموضوع الانتاج ايه السبب كده هل ده عيب
خلقي في المصريين لا بالتاكيد لان نقطه
مهمه جدا
اود ان انتهز هذه المناسبه للاشاره اليها
الا وهي
في اي اقتصاد واي مجتمع لكي تدار شؤونه
باتزان وباستدامه
في اطار من الاستقرار لابد ان يحكم
الموضوع مبدا حمل للغايه اللي هو ايه
وجود علاقه بين الجهد المبذول من الفرد
والعائله
تاني انه بني ادم بيشقى ويتعب ويعرق وهو
الاخر وينتج وبعدين يجي يمد ايدي دي عشان
نشوف الدخل ايه يعني
محدود جدا
واحد تاني
قاعد على القهوه بيتكلم في التليفون يعمل
صفقات
ايحاء ملايين
فده مثال صارخ لاضطراب العلاقه بين الجهد
المبذول والقاعده وبالمناسبه لموضوع مش
وليد السنوات التمانيه اللي فاتت في
الحقيقه لو نظرت الى تاريخ مصر لفتره
ممتاز يمكن خليني ارجع لحتى الاتنين
رغم التطور والتقدم اللي حصل في مصر بعدها
انما كان برده
قالت ثقه واهل الخبره في سياق معين هذه
ثقه يحصلون على
ما يحصلون عليه واهل الخبره رغم الكد
والكدح والكلام ده يعني
وبالتالي بقول انه السبب الحاله اللي احنا
عايشين فيها هو انه لم نضع قاعده
نؤسس لها
ونشرع لها
ونطبقها بمنتهى الدقه والحزم والاستمراريه
توجد علاقه بين الجهد المبذول والعائله
العازيه عظيم طيب اتفضل
اذا نتج عن هذا نتج عن هذا انصراف
الاغلبيه عن الانتاج
وبالتالي لما انصرف الاغلبيه عن الانتاج
قدرتك على الانتاج ضعفت
واحتياجاتك لازداد الفجوه بين ما تنتجه
ويتحول لدخول
وما تحتاج اليه لتزداد بنتكلم على فجوتين
دايما كده في الخطاب بتاع الحكومه اللي هو
فجوه الموارد وفجوه النقد للنادي الاجنبي
وبالتالي النتيجه احنا محتاجين لقروض هي
دي النقطه انت ما عليك المشكله
دي نقطه النقطه التانيه انه
تاكيدا لفكره
اهمال الانتاج انه القطاعات الاساسيه في
اي اقتصاد هي الزراعه والصناعه هكذا يقول
الاقتصاديون وهكذا يعلمنا التاريخ
اي اقصاد يهمل هذه القطاعين لابد ان يصاب
مشكلات على المسير الخاصه واحنا في الواقع
اهملنا الاتنين
الاهمال زاد في السنوات الثماني الاخيره
رغم كل ما يقال انك انت عندك مشروع
المليون فدان ومشروع
ريف المصري وكل الكلام ده جميل لكن دي
الخلفيه
سياسات
تضحي بالفلاح
على مذبح اقتصاد الدوله لك ان تتامل مثلا
كيفيه معامله الفلاح المنتج للارز وكيفيه
معامله الفلاح لمنتج القمح وانا هنا اتحدث
في الواقع من موقعي ليس اقتصادي وسياسي
وانما من خلفيتك فلاح قد لا يعلم الساده
اللي بيتابعونا واود ان يعلموا ذلك ان انا
مارست الفلاحه في اول 12 سنه من عمري مش
يعني ما كنتش مزاول املاك انما كنت في
الغيط اقوم كل المهام اللي بيقوم بها
الفلاح من ان انا ادور الساقيه وحول الميه
وحمل الحمار لا مؤاخذه كل الكلام ده وعارف
كيف يعامل الايد فلما تهمل الزراعه
امنك الغذائي يصبح على المحك ومعه الامن
القومي من انه اساس الامن القومي هو الامن
الغذائي طبعا في الامن العسكري وانواع
اخرى على الاطلاق هو الامن الايه بسبب
اهمال الزراعه ومصر في الواقع يعني ليست
غنيه في مريض الزراعيه لكن هي ليست فقيره
ايضا في مر الزراعيه لانه ابسط شيء انه
ليعلم الجميع ليعلم الجميع انه ارض الدلتا
والوادي هي اخصب الاراضي في اي مكان في
العالم
وهيبه من الله استودعنا اياها
تكونت عبر ملابس السنين وتحتاج في التعامل
معها لمنتدى منتهى الحرص والحذر
يبقى معنى الكلام
مخصصش اراضي
لشخص ما دون ذكرى اسماء عشان يصص لحها
وزرعها وبعدين يفضل سايبها بور يسقعها
وبعدين يجي يقدم طلب والله انا عايز
احولها الى مباني وقد كان كثير من هذه
الظاهره ظاهره منتشره جدا في زمننا هذا
فاذا ما عندكش سياسه زراعيه واتكلمنا اظن
في حلقه سابقه عن دور امريكا في من خلال
مشروع البحوث الايه البحوث الزراعيه فدي
واحد بالنسبه للصناعه
سمعنا اذكر وانا شاب في الواقع
انه كان لو تسال الطلبه عايز تروح فين
يقول لك الروح كليه الهندسه طبعا بتوع
ادبي زي حالاتي كليه الاقتصاد ماشي انما
معظم التربه الهندسيه والطب ليه لانه في
ذلك الحين كان عندنا سياسه صناعيه كان
عندنا مصانع بتنشا في مختلف انحاء مصر
بحري والصعيد والقاهره واسكندريه
ومنطقه القناه وبالتالي طالع اللي بيتخرج
وكان حتى داخل التخصصات الهندسه يقول لك
امكانيكا لانه المصانع معناها ميكانيكي
بتتكلم على الستينات
يعني لغايه اواخر السمات وكان تجليات هذا
انك انت تدخل الاجزخانه
تلاقي فرشه سنان انتاج مصري تلاقي معجون
سنان المصري
يمكن الناس تستغرب جدا لانه حاليا لا يوجد
شيء بهذا الشكل على الاطلاق تدخل لازخانه
احيانا نتخانق يا جدع انا عايز يقول لي لا
مع الاسف ما فيش خلاص كويس
ده على مستوى انما مثلا تاخد سلعيه زي
عندنا اهف في وقت من الاوقات كانت مش كده
اصل في ناس بيتابعونا مش مصريين فعشان
يبقوا في الصوره يعني
شركه كانت بتنتج مواد غذائيه
شركه من شركات القطاع العام وكانت في وقت
من الاوقات يعني
تتوهج من ناحيه النشاط والانتاجيه دلوقتي
اصبحت
فيست وبعدين فشلت في الخصاصه فاعيدت
للدوله مره تانيه فاذا
ليس لديك سياسه صناعيه
وكل ما انت مهتم به وما يسمى الجذب للصغار
له مقاومات كثيره جدا ولكن
الاساس لابد من
تطوير البيئه الداخليه لتوسيع النطاق
الاستثمار فاذا احنا اهملنا
الزراعه اهملنا الصناعه
ونتج عن هذا بالفعل سياسات الانفتاح
والخصاصه والكلام ده كله انه العلاقات بين
قطاعات الاقتصاد المصري في الداخل بعدها
وبعد ضعفت وتقلصه والعلاقات بنازل
القطاعات والخارج زادت وتمددت هذه مثال
في استناد والى حد ما في السبانات كان
العلاقه بين الزراعه والصناعه في مصر
علاقه قويه ليه لانك زراعه كانت بتنتج سلع
الاجريه اللي هي القمح والارز وخلافه
وبتنتج ايضا القطن اللي هو سلعه صناعيه
بامتياز هذا القطن ينتقل من الزراعه الى
الصناعه لكي يتحول الى غزل ونسيج وملابس
بدي العلاقات اللي هي يعني داخليه ما بين
الزراعه والصناعه مع مرور الوقت
مع الخصخصه وبيع القطاع العام واحمال
الزراعه اصبح انت في الواقع
الامداد الذي ياتي لصناعه الغاز والنسيج
داخليا من الزراعه المصريه تراجع
وحل محله انتاج الغير اصبحت تستورد قطب من
الخارج لاداره هذه الصناعات
وبهذا الوضع ينطبق على صناعات كثيره انه
حصل خلخله للاقتصاد وبالمناسبه يعني
نستورد قطن الاخرين من جانب الصناعه بقى
المنسوجات المنسوجات عندك مع التحول
عن الصناعه بعض المصانع مثلا خذ مثال محل
الكبرى المحله الكبرى يعني طبعا دلوقتي
بيعاد يحيىها ولكن هي كانت قلعه صناعيه
بامتياز منذ انشاها طلعت باشا حرب
الكلام ده كان في العشرينات من القرن
الماضي ليعلم حوالي 100 سنه وفي
لما حولنا نامن في الستينات من اهم
الصناعات التي
فاذا النقطه دي عايز افسر بس ليه الهشاشه
ودي لا اساس علمي احنا درسنا يعني في بنت
سنه فاتت
نشرنا دراسه وعرضناها في مؤتمر انتم من
احد تلاميذي كويس كده مبنيه على قياس
وحسابات ويعني ليس كلام مرسل
وطلع عبر 50 سنه من استنانات لغايه اللحظه
الحاليه هناك تخلخل في هيكل الانتاج بمعنى
انه تزايد ترابط القطاعات الاقتصاديه
المصريه مع الخارج
وتضاؤل ترابطها مع بعضها البعض في الموضوع
يحتاج الى وقفه شديده جدا واللي يتابع
تجربه تنميه في بلاد زي اليابان وكوريا
يدرك اهميه الانتباه الى هذه طب قبل ما
يعني احاول الخص اللي حضرتك قلته عشان
اتاكد ان انا فهمته صح هل ممكن بس تدينا
تعريف لان الكلام يبدو الترابط الداخلي
يعني التخلخل الروابط الداخليه وعمق
العلاقات مع الخارج يبدو كلام ممكن يكون
صعب شويه هل في مثال بسيط تقصد ان المفروض
يعني ان قطاعات الانتاج في مصر تبقى
مترابطه او في اي بلد
فيما ان الحارس ان احنا بنربط نفسينا اكتر
باحتياجات السوق الخارجي هل ممكن توضح
مثال من
مجال الحديد والصلب كويس انت كان عندك
شركه
في الواقع
مصنع متكامل بمعنى كيف بتاخد الحديد من
مناجم الحديد الموجوده في البدايه حاليا
وبعدين اتنقلنا للوحات البحريه عندك ركاز
من خام الحديد درجه تركيز الحديد في مش
اعلى الدرجات انما معقول تقدر تستعملها
وبتنقل داخل بالك يعني عندك منجم بتنقله
بالسكه الحديد في ادي من
قطاع المناجم والتعدين الى قطاع النقل صح
السكه الحديد ده نشاط وبتنقله الى جنوب
القاهره في التبين
المصانع بتحولوا اولا الى حديد ثم الى صلب
ثم الى منتجات فيليه في النهايه هذه
المنتجات تطلع بقى من المصنع تروح
صناعات هندسيه صناعات سيارات ادوات منزليه
معدات
مثلا في في فتره حرب الاستنزاف كان دي
واحده من الانشطه المهمه جدا وانت بتبني
دفاعات غرب القناه
فانت عندك قطاعات تعديل
مترابط مع قطاع نقل مترابط من قطاع انتاج
ادي معنى التداخل طبعا مرتبط بقطاع
الانشاء والعقارات الى اخره لما بالضبط
كده لما قفلت مصنع
مصانع الشركه المصريه والصلب مؤخرا من كام
سنه
ايه النتيجه بقى دلوقتي لو كان قبل كده
كمان كان شركه الكوك بتغذي
شركه حلو الصلب بالكوك اللي هو مهم
العمليات الانتاج الحديد تمام فاصبح انت
فككت كل الكلام ده واضطريت في مرحله ما
انك انت تقفل كمان شركه ايه الكوك لانه
كانت معتمده على شركه حيث صلب والحديد
والصلب معتمد عليها فلما حصل وقفلت الحيز
الصلب الطريق تقفل الكوك واصبح حاليا يا
اما تستورد مكورات الحديد من الخارج اللي
بيسموها لانتاج
مثلا ارتفاع اسعار النقل اضطراب في اسواق
العملات فسعر عملتها يتراجع كل الكلام ده
ينعكس بشكل واضح جدا وشديد على الاقتصاد
بصوره سلبيه ده معنى الهشاشه طيب هل
تازلني ان انا الخص واسال حضرتك سؤال
حضرتك بتقولوا ان ملخص الثمن سنوات
الماضيه انه الحكومات المتعاقبه لم تنجح
في تحقيق الكفاءه الاقتصاديه يعني ما
قدرتش ان هي تولد اكبر قدر ممكن من العائد
من الموارد المخصصه لها الامر الثاني انه
ما قدرناش نحقق او ما قدروش نحقق العداله
الاجتماعيه واكتفوا بما يسمى الحمايه انك
حد تكافل وكرامه الى اخره كذا وانه
النتيجه عدم وجود كفاءه اقتصاديه وعدم
وجود عداله اجتماعيه بقى عندنا هشاشه
الهشاشه ديت بتتضح ببساطه جدا انا مع اي
صدمه خارجيه الاقتصاد يعاني انا السؤال
اللي بيلحها علي جدا انه حضرتك بتشخص
تقريبا هل الاقتصاد المصري في سنوات طويله
مش في الثمان سنوات يعني هل هيكون من
المنصف انه نقول هذا ما حدث في الثمان
سنوات الماضيه هو غير صحيح الكلام ده اذا
كان المقصود انه ما هذا ما حدث في السنوات
الثمن الماضيه فقط لا هذا اتجاه كان موجود
وبدا في مصر تحديدا منذ منتصف السبعينات
دعني اقول يعني داخلين انا حوالي خمسين
سنه هذا الاتجاه شغال مع عباد السياسي
لمفتاح واستمر في 30 سنه بتاع حكم مبارك
انما الوتيره بتاعه هذا الاتجاه زادت بشكل
ملحوظ جدا في الثواني في السنوات الاخيره
اذا في حضرتك بتقول ان ما حدث في الثمان
سنوات هو امتداد لسنوات خمسين مضت بدات به
سياسات الانفتاح اللي انا هرجع لحضرتك في
مناقشتها في حلقات المقبله ان شاء الله
اذا سمح وقتك انما برضو سؤالين سؤال
بصراحه بيلوحها علي اذا كان في اجابه ارجو
ان صدرك يتسع لي احد الاسئله دي بيقولوا
للدكتور جوده رجل يساري مش بمعنى يساري
بقى بالتعريف بس
يعني بمعنى دايما على يسار السلطه فمهما
فعلت السلطه الدكتور جوده مش راضي هيكون
دائما بينتقدهم هو على يسار السلطه مش على
يمينها ابدا
اولا من حقي ان انا عارف حقوق كويس جدا
لكن
مش صحيح الكلام ده يعني مثلا
ارجع بالذاكره عده سنوات فقط حينما ظهرت
فكره
شق التفريع
الجنوبيه لقناه السويس
واللي نازج عنها ازدواج الحركه عبر القناه
انا لاحظت انه
الترويج لهذا المشروع في الاعلام ونوع
الخبر اللي كان بيجي يتكلموا
بيقدموا اتفه الاسباب
واضعافها للدفاع عن المشروع فطلب دي كان
اول مره في حياتي اطلب من تلفزيون الدوله
ان انا اطلع اتكلم
كلمت رئيس قطاع الاخبار ترقص بقى برنامج
صباح الخير يا مصر ده
بتشوف الناس من في مصر من اقساط انا شايف
انه
تقديرا لخطوره مشروع التفريعه انا عايز
اتكلم يعني بسمع كلام لا مؤاخذه خايف في
الموضوع فقال لي اهلا وسهلا رتب لي لقاء
استمرار ساعه وربع واتكلمنا في الموضوع
وامتدحت المشروع طبعا لا قدمت دفاع يعني
رصين عن المشروع وكيف ان مشروع له جدان
وبتسمع كلام خايب
سواء من المؤيدين للمشروع
ده مشروع حيوي واستراتيجي اذا كنت وقومي
بتتكلم على مشروع قومي فهو هذا الكلام عن
مشروع استراتيجي هو هذا بيتكلم مشروع
اقتصادي المردود بتاع فهو هذا انما في
حاجات صغيره بتحصل في الاثناء زي مثلا
احنا عملناها في الوقت اللي كان في ركود
على
التجاره لم تنمو والحركه المرور لم تزداد
بما انت وسعت المجرى
الامور ولكن ما فيش طلب مش لانه في مشكله
في المشروع يعني الظروف الدوليه وانما
دلوقتي بدات الحركه تزداد وابتدى يبان فده
انا عايز اقول مش في كل الاحوال السلطه لا
احب قبل ما اختم ونتكلم عن تفصيلته في
حلقات اخرى مره تانيه بتقول كيف يمكن ان
نخرج من هذا النفق احنا دلوقتي احنا على
اعتاب فتره رئاسيه جديده على الارجح ما لم
تحدث معجزه هو الرئيس الحالي الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي سوف يكون رئيسا لمصر لس ت
سنوات الاخرى كيف ترى انه يمكن
اذا استمع يعني اصحاب القرار انه ممكن
يتحسن الوضع الاقتصادي
اتفضل قدم بالتفصيل اول شيء
لما نبدا المرحله الجديده اللي هي الولايه
اللي اتمنى ان تكونوا ليها الاخيره للرئيس
السيسي اتصور انه اول شيء لابد ان نراجع
نظرتنا الى الخارج
وموقعنا على خريطه العالم احنا من الضعفاء
ولكن نحن لسنا اضع في الاطراف
ولدينا اوراق يمكن ان نستخدمه بكفاءه
للدفاع عن وجودنا وعن امننا
بمعنى ايه الكلام بمعنى انه انت
لا اقول
فلنودل زهران
للمؤسسات اللي اتكلمت عنها في لقاء سابق
النقد والبنك الدوله
العالميه
ساشتبك معه ولكن من منظور مختلف الوضع
الحالي هو ده سر المشكله باكد عليه انك
انت في في حكم المتلقي
تستمع الى ما يقوله الصندوق ويتصور
الكثيرون انه هو ده
الصح غير صحيح غير صحيح خبراء الصندوق
حينما يفيدون الى مصر بالمناسبه
ينزلون في فنادق خمس نجوم لا يرون من
القاهره الى النيل العظيم
والمكاتب الحكوميه الفخمه وهم في عزله
تماما عما يحدث على ارض الواقع
واعتقد انه لو مسؤولين كانوا بنفس طريقه
وبالتالي انا بقول نغير
معنى كده ايه
اذا كنت هتوجه للصندوق النقد انا اعتقد
انه ينبغي ان يستبعد تماما موضوع التخفيض
الجنيه تماما يعني لا يكون وارد في اي
نقاشات انا عارف الصندوق بيلوحها لكن انا
ممكن اقل اقدم كمصري كمصري مع حاجه وطنيه
لاثبات ان هذا هو اسوا البدايه على انك
انت ليه سبب بسيط برضو عشان اللي بيتابعني
يبقى عارف ليه انت وليه بتخفض اصلا خفض
عشان
تحسن وضعك في التعامل التجاري الدولي تزيد
من صادراتك وتقلل من طيب لكي يحدث ذلك في
شروط اقتصاديه طبعا
عبر عنها بمعالات بمعادلات رياضيه معقده
اسمها شرط ميرشر
خاص بالمورناد بس انا بارجو المشاهدين
يزرف اللي انا عايز اقوله عندك قاعده
انتاجيه
تمكنك في الواقع من تعزيز موقعك
على مستوى الصادرات الى العالم الخارجي
وفي نفس الوقت تمكنك من
الاستغناء عن بعض ما يتم استيراده من
الخارج
اذا تحقق ذلك بعيده عن التفاصيل يبقى
معناها التعويم مفيد ليه لانه هيمكنك من
زياده تصدير ومن تقليل الثراء فيتحسن
الميزان التجاري ويتحسن ميزان المدفوعات
وبالتالي تقل حاجه الى الاستدانه وضعك
الاقتصادي ينفرج في نهايتي ليه
هناك اشياء اخرى لما يزيد الانتاج يزيد
التشغيل
والدنيا تبقى احسن تمام طيب ايه المشكله
طب ازاي ده ما بيحصلش في حالتها بسيط انت
عندك اللي اتكلمنا عليه نحاس الخلخله
لقطاعات الانتاج في اصبحت اكثر ارتباطا
بالخارج من
ترابطاتها الداخليه
تاخد اي صناعه او اي نشاط دلوقتي تجد
اعتماده على مكونات خارجيه خوات خارجيه
عالي جدا في احدى الدراسات الميدانيه
مدينه الصناعيه زي مدينه العاشر من رمضان
نسبه المكون الاجنبي في المنتج النهائي
اللي بتعمله في المتوسط 70% بعد حالات
الخيال 70% يعني انت لو بتنتج 100 دولار
سبعين في منهم عباره عن امور جايه من
الخارج معنى الكلام ده ايه انه لما تخفض
الجنيه هترتفع الواردات تكلفه الانتاج
وبالتالي ده بيقلل من التنفسيه التي يتيح
لك الايه التخفيض فكانك ابو زيد فضلا عن
ذلك بيرفع بقى المستوى العام الاسعار على
خلفيه احتياجاتك الغذائيه اللي هي بتصل
الى حدود 50% من الخارج
وبالتالي انا بقول اوكي نتعامل مع الصندوق
مع البنك ولكن نقرا بعنايه جدا جدا النصوص
اللي بتقدم لنا
ونقبل ما يتطابق مع مصلحتنا ونرفض ما
يتعارض
طبعا ده يشترط اننا نتخلص من الحاله
الذهنيه العجيبه دي ان انا بنظر نازل على
انهم شركاء التربيه وانه هم بيقدمونا
تمويلات وهم ناس فعلت الخير حتى انه يا
راجل احنا مدهش جدا لانه من اهم الاشياء
اللي لفت نظر المسؤولين بمناسبه دعوه مصر
للدخول للبريكس في قال لك ده هيتحلل
الحصول على التمولات شيء معقول يعني
شوف كيف اختزلت المسائل
الى هذا الحد ده ما في في حاول في الرؤيه
عفوا للتعبير انما انا بقوله وانا مطمئن
جدا
حوال في الرؤيه ويحتاج الى التصحيح بتعمل
نظارات بقى في نظارات بتتعمل للناس لما
يكون عندها حواء في الراي لكن هذا حاول في
الرؤيه من بدء التخلص دي نمره واحد
داخليا بقى تعمل ايه داخليه
احنا رفعنا شعار العقارات ده لفتره استمرت
من اهم اواخر ايام مبارك في الوفاء
التمددات الخارج الخيار اللي بين القاهره
نفسيه اللي بنشوفها دي تجد جزرها من من
ايام انما الوضع زاد جدا اداريه انه
الحكومه داخل مش الدوله بقى الحكومه داخل
بتقولها جدا
كمطور عقاري
وبياع للارض
ارض المباني واقامه مباني وبيع كل الكلام
هذا ليس من شان الحكومه وانا اتساءل هل
تدخل الحكومه في هذا السوق اللي هو سوق
العقارات والاراضي
ادى الى نتيجه ايجابيه ولا سلبيه ده سؤال
اتمنى الحكومه تتوقف عند في تقديري انه
اكثر ليه سبب لانه انت ما احتكار الحكومه
الارض دي اصلا اللي بتبيعها وتشتريه ارض
الشعب مش ارض الحكومه بنقص الدستور جزء من
الموارد لو خدت مفهوم الدوله الدوله جزء
منها الشعب وجزء تاني للحكومه وجزء ثالث
الارض خلاص ده الوطن دوله طيب التدخل
الدوله في رايي في مجال العقارات يحتاج
الى مراجعه شديده جدا جدا يعني ولكن
الفكره كلها ان انا عايز الحكومه
تركز على قطاعات الانتاج الزراعه والصناعه
اوكي لو لو بدانا في هذا الاتجاه ستتحقق
مكاسب كبيره جدا يقل اعتمادك على الخالق
تزداد صلواتك في مواجهه الصدمات الخارجيه
تمام
لكن
بالاضافه الى ذلك ارجع لما بدات به ولا هو
مبدا الكفاءه الاقتصاديه لابد ان يخضع كل
مشروع كل مشروع
تسميه قومي او القومي مش مشكله انما كله
مشروع اقتصادي في اي مكان في بر مصر
لحسابات دقيقه جدا للتكلفه اللي احنا
اقتصادين بيسموه دراسات جدوى تدرس قبل ما
تنفذ مشروع لما يكون فكره تدرسها عشان
انما ينفذ على ارض الواقع هل سيؤدي الى
عوائد تفوخ تكاليفه ولا العكس اذا كان
يؤدي الى عوائق تفوق تكاليفه يبقى له
مردود مثلا مشروع تفريعه قناه سويس اللي
تحدثنا انما انا عندي شك كبير على ماء اذا
كان مثلا عوائد مشهور العاصمه الاداريه
الجديده ولا العلمين الجديده على سبيل
المثال عواده اكتر من التكاليفه
بالنسبه للمجتمع قد يكون بالنسبه للحكومه
ماشي انما الحديث هنا حديث عن حسابات
تكلفه ولا عادي المجتمعيه وليست الايه
الحكوميه يكمل الكلام ده كله بقى نبدا
الكفاءه الاقتصاديه لابد ان يحترم ومبدا
العداله الاجتماعيه لانه الكفاءه حريق
وضحتها بدراسات الجدوى
العداله الاجتماعيه معناها انه يوجد قدر
معقوله مقبول وده بينصب الصوره في اكثر
ماده في الدستور بتحدد هويه النظام
الاقتصادي ان يقوم على العداله الاجتماعيه
وما تركز فيه الحكومه حاليا فقط هو
الحمايه الاجتماعيه عايز اقول الحمايه
الاجتماعيه طريق مسدود ليه لانه انت بتدي
تمويل
بصوره او اخرى وفي سقف العمليه دي مربوط
الموازنه العامه للدوله والكلام ده زائد
انه ليس هو الحل للمستلام الحل المستلام
هو العداله الاجتماعيه على النحو اللي
احنا وضحناه اخيرا اخيرا ان تهتم ان تهتم
بالتعليم والصحه
لانه وده منظور مختلف عن منظور الحكومه
تماما انا انظر للموضوع السكاني
والحجم مصر سكاني على انه ميزه
ونعمه
وليس خطرا ولا ضرر على الاطلاق انما محتاج
ان انا استثمر فيه القادم المناسب في
مجالي التعليم والصحه يبقى معناها انه
ممكن جدا يبقى عندك قوه ضاربه اقتصاديه
العقل السليم في الجسم السليم عندك تعليم
وصحه
ومن الامور التي تقلقني حاليا على خلفيه
ارتفاع الاسعار ان يحدث اضرار بشريه لا
يمكن تداركها مهما عملت بعد كده
العلماء بيقولوا علماء التغذيه بيقولوا
انه في مراحل
السن الاولى لو من سنه لتلات صحيح اذا لم
يحصل الطفل على القدر الكافي والمتوازي من
الغذاء يحصلوا مشاكل في عقله وفي جسمه لا
يمكن اصلاحها بعد كده يعني
ما ينفعش الكلام اوكي انا هستاذن حضرتك
احنا نقف عند مساله تحقيق العداله
والتركيز على الصحه والتعليم ونتركها
لحلقات اخرى لان انت برضو في اسئله كتيره
طب من اين هيئه التمويل واين والترتيب
الاولويات الى اخره
وهنلاقي بعض التعليقات او بعض من
المتابعين يشتبكوا طب ما الكلام
نقوله بس نعمله ازاي فاستاذنك نرجئ هذه
الاسئله حلقه اخرى نتحدث فيها عما يجب ان
يتم من وجهه نظر حضرتك شكرا جزيلا على
الدكتور عفوا وشكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم
ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى ان شاء الله
مع الدكتور جوده عبد الخالق